hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 2020 chess table masters it's
Magnus Carlsen versus onigiri and this
is Game two of the Match Game one ended
in a draw we are here to find out is it
only Gary's destiny to meet Carlsen or
to actually beat him now without further
ado let's check it out Magnus with the
white pieces opens with E 4 and we are
heading into another Berlin we have e5
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5
so the rule opus is on the board we have
Knight of 6 the Berlin defence and the
d3 now so the line pretty much everyone
is playing now Bishop to c5 end captures
on c6 we have D captures and c6 and now
Knight to c3 so a fairly standard stuff
Queen to e7 by year here now defending
the e5 pawn this way not going for for
any Knight to d7 action and h3 by Magnus
and here that there are a couple of
games for Knight to d7 was played but
here the movie get replaced is a new
move
he goes for b6 and it's already as of
move 7 that we have a completely new
game so be be b6 has been played that
you can now develop the light square
Bishop either this way although and very
unlikely
so a3 preparing to kick away the bishop
would be 4 and h6 by giri we have Queen
to e2 and now Bishop to d7 preparing to
Castle queenside with Bishop to e3 by
Magnus and the characters on e3 and now
you could character with the pawn or
with the Queen I guess it depends on
what kind of game do you want to play
Magnus decides the character with the F
phone I changes the the character of the
position a little bit and it does
strengthen your center so you will have
the option of going d4 at some point and
you still have the option of casting
both King side and Queen side so here we
have a castles Queen side and now comes
Queen to F to Magnus wants to shift the
Queen over to g3 and create a double
attack on the e5 pawn and now Knight the
EI the giri of course is waiting for
this and she wants to play f6 to block
the the attack on the e5 pawn so Queen
g3 Magnus continues and now f6 defense
so this is defended this is defended
everything is nice
defend it but as everything nice is
nicely defended it also did weakened the
lights worse here so Magnus immediately
wants to occupy the lights course nights
the h4 now going for the f5 square here
that's not an f5 square and work the g8
now preparing to go for g5 we have
Knight to f5 and now you can't really
move the Queen there are no good squares
for the Queen here it's just well it's
just uh not not a good nova squares for
the Queen you do have to care a capture
this night you could go to a fight or
something like that but it's not not
pleasant yeah so instead giver decides
to eliminate this night but in doing so
he undoes calls and spawns so E
characters on f5 and out Knight to d6
getting the knight to a more active
Square attacking f5 and here Magnus
defended with E 4 and now Magnus has a
fine control of the center here and it
could be it could be problematic for for
a giri if this pawn remains on g7 so he
immediately goes Queen to f7
he doesn't want to be stuck with a g7
backwards pawn and he wants to push it
maybe the G 4G Jesus but also maybe g5
so Queen back to f2 by Magnus and we
have g6 Magnus captures we have
characters captures and now Magnus also
would like to have another target to go
after the f6 pawn is is the backwards
pawn so he wants to keep it there so he
goes G G for keeping an eye on DF v
square and not allowing this point to be
pushed to f5 and of course if you if you
allow white to just pile up on the f6
pawn that will be very unpleasant so
Gary immediately goes h5 he wants to
create a target here and he wants to
trade this guy for this guy here and
Magnus says okay I'm gonna Castle
queenside let's do this
so captures captures we have captures
and g4 end captures on f6 and now a nice
Queen trade Queen to g5 with check we
have Queen captures and g5 and now rook
captures on g5 and we have this two
rooks and Night vs five points for each
side and okay GUI does have a CC pawn
but it's
not that big of a deal so we have a four
by Magnus and a five by giri rook D to G
one and just rugby to g8 by giri now
threatening to pick up the rooks on
Magnus trades once we have characters
characters in the now Knights to be one
REE manoeuvring the night maybe two III
maybe to have two depends on what on
what black plays sorry not tonight City
One Nights to be one every maneuvering
the night to d2 and then from there you
will have some nice control of the C 4
square as you are expecting black to
play C 5 and C 4 he does have a CC pond
so of course he wants to get rid of it
so by playing Knight to d2 you will have
nice control of c4 with b5 by gearing
and now Knights to be to Magnus
continues as planned we have rook to g3
and now b3 defending da for pawn with B
characters be captures in the now c5 so
Geary of course would like to play c4
but for the moment it is protected twice
so Knights the f1 now kicking back the
rook we have rook to three and now King
to d1
allowing Yuri this freeing c4 moves so
he Giri goes forward we have C 4 and now
King to eat you attacking the rook rook
back to f7 and now Knight to d2 again
now just threatening to win the pawn
here but the giri even allows it he goes
rook the g7 and even if you capture the
pawn it's not not the greatest of pawns
at this point is now a double upon the
knight is stuck here now guarding the
two pawns and let's say after you give a
check King d1 you have to keep an eye on
the night here rule goes back and now
the pawn let's say will fall so instead
after this rook to g7 move with King to
f3
now just allowing the trade to happen
but King to b7 giri also starts
improving the position of his own king
we have looked at h5 going after the h5
pawn and here's a very interesting
moment in the game here Gary doesn't
defend it with King to e6
which does seem like like a move but
rather goes to rook to g1 he wants to go
for an active plan followed by rook to
c1 and then go after Carlsen
queenside pawns and Magnus says okay
rook captures on e5 let's see let's see
what you got
Giri goes rook to c1 and now Knight
captures on c4
we have night cap prison C for D
captures and rook captures and c2 and
now after all is said and done rook
captures rook captures we get this rook
and pawn in game where Magnus is up upon
but it should be it should be possible
to hold this to a draw so rook the d5
check by Magnus King to e6 and now a
five getting the point out of harm's way
and the Giri goes rook the c1 not going
for rook day for right away he says we
will have time for that maybe he can
also start pushing his own passed pawn
but now rook the d8 by Magnus we look to
f1 check kicking away the King King e2
and only now rook to a-1 attacking the
past pawn here rook to e8 Magnus defends
it and now King to d6 so Magnus has to
figure out a way how to how to start
pushing both of his pawns so of course
a6 that bone can be pushed king to c6
and now King to III by Magnus and now
it's it's a very very tricky to find a
move here for black for example if King
to b6 then you continue pushing the e5
pawn and it's it's very tricky c5
doesn't seem to be to be fast enough for
black and if you try something like
let's say rook captures on a6 then you
can just trade and the King is no longer
well in the in the square of the pawn
you can just continue with these six and
it is that the King is much too far away
from from the square of the pawn so
after King to e3 Gary tried rook to e1
check and not even tricky one trick and
now King to f4 we have King to b6 going
after the pawn are not allowing the room
to move and now II five by Magnus
we have c5 Geary also starts pushing his
passport and now rook the c8 Magnus gets
rid of tries to get rid of the ace
exponent by capturing this one and this
doesn't really go or go a blacks way
since the King is now completely caught
off and you are never getting even close
to that pawn it would be easily winning
for white so instead after worked the c8
we have rook to f1 check by Geary
but now
GFI we have looked at g1 Czech king f6
and now rook the f1 check King to e7 and
now look the c1 again preparing to pull
it upon also you want to capture without
losing the C pawn but now e 6 now giri
also starts pushing this passed pawn we
have C 4 and now King to d7 preparing to
finish the job here we have Group D 1
check King to e8 and now look back to
see one defending the pawn but now e 7
and now how do you continue this with
black well Giri pushes c3 but now a king
to f7 and here a Giri starts the series
of checks which is well basically the
only thing you're left with so look f1
check King to g6 and now look the g1
with check King f5 rook to f1 check King
to g4 and it was in this position after
King to g4 was played that onigiri
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here a few more checks
and you are promoting this to a queen
it's not a problem check check check and
after you go here or e2 even better for
that matter it's just game over the rook
has to move and after the rook moves you
you get a queen into the game and that's
it so good start for Magnus he wins he
wins Game two and two more games of
rapid in in the first match so we'll see
what happens and if we will well have
some sort of a comeback and will we go
it into the blitz blitz playoffs and
maybe even to Armageddon so really a
nicely nicely in the freshly squeezed
stone not it's hard hard to even say
where we're gearing I I imagine it's
somewhere around this point here where
he decided to go for it for the active
rook to g1 planned instead of instead of
king days just defending the pawn but
it's hard to say I mean these guys are
no no their endgame so well that maybe
even this is well just because it's
maybe a bit more passive for black it's
too difficult to hold but you know who
knows so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Armin
Steven Steven surgeon Casa Grande Robert
Kruger now ya knew Bannen and
Jeff graves for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos Sara thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the 2020
chasuble Master finals checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do join
us in the stream today later on see you
soon guys